bonjour monsieur le maire est là il a
dérapé il ya un instant se réhabiliter
applaudissements polis bravo jean mais
alors qu'est ce que vous voulez m je
vais m'excuser déjà brouyère j'avais
fait une sortie qui était pas très fine
alors c'est vrai que hier justement
d'ailleurs hier on a on a fait une
petite compil de votre émission d'hier
et vous allez voir vous êtes trouvé
comment vous hier il n'y a pas que du
bon vous allez voir je crois même qu'il
n'y a eu que du mauvais
19h12 jean-mi a oublié qu'il avait
émissions aujourd'hui jean michel maire
19h36 gens n'y a pas une vanne que lui
il comprend alors on parle de quoi
ces lettres majuscules minuscules 19h39
jean-mi à une pulsion les alors c'est
quoi à rien q pour une fois 20h23 gens
me fait une vanne sur les poupées
gonflables pour rappeler quand même à
ceux qui seraient tentés il faut pas
voir this trop pointu parce que ça peut
exploser autres bassiste 20h24 jean-mi a
encore une pulsion combat de film avec
gérard jugnot ont dépassé le million de
spectateurs au cinéma sans peur non qui
des loups ohlala
20h41 gens n'y pensent à voix haute
sanaga gdm auriez donc le manteau 46
cyril arrête le massacre terminée mais
il faut pas rester là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que les téléspectateurs que je
rappelle que je suis payé malheureuse
non je m'appelais ils paraissent aller
d'ailleurs dans un instant on jouera
tout le monde nous prendrons pas jouer
avec votre argent belle idée et vous
allez jouer pour gagner l'argent dérobé
les bijoux et oui alors non non vous
alors prendre et d'argent qui déclare
mais tout le monde veut prendre sa thune
vous jouez avec nous à ce tag jeu tout
de suite hashtag ajouté pmp et vous
gagnerez la moitié de la somme puisque
chacun 20 mètres 50 euros vous serez 10
y aura 500 euros pour à 250 euros pour
le téléspectateur directs et 250 euros
pour le grand gagnant qui n y aura 250
euros de ses petits camarades
non on m'a dit oui on verra ça te merde
alors oui donc c'était suite cela
possible
regretter de ne pas avoir eu une
aventure avec lui j'ai entendu ça vous
confirme à sa me confiant alors oui je
les appelais le modestement lettre un
cube
c'était la lettre q oui j'avoue cyril
j'ai vu un cul apparaître derrière vous
et alors what the fuck que celui d'entre
vous qui n'a pas maté ce qu me jette la
première pierre
pierre tu l'as pas vu toi mathieu quoi
mon cul jeu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et toi géraldine il t'inspire toujours
pas pas à montcuq toujours là et toi
bouder t'as pas envie de bouffer au la
combattons chocolatées jeudi et astuces
en tout cas on fait une belle paire tous
de faux cul parce que tout le monde
l'avait vu cette lettre alors pardon oui
d'en parler trop souvent mais n'oubliez
pas que darien un gros lourd se cache ou
un grand sentimental je cherche
désespérément l'amour cyril ça mérite un
peu de gens ce nom ps gros nichons
apprécié j'avoue je les passions du ps
en levée de baisse gentil alors d'en
sortir le ps pas de nichons jean michel
est ce qu'on le réhabilite oui on va
voir pour combien de temps